(jazz music)
- When I first started in the wig business
the hair alone could
be up to $175 an ounce.
Let's just say, there was more
money in hair than heroin.
My stock of hair right now
is probably worth over a million dollars.
My name is Nicholas
Piazza, and I'm a wigmaker,
hair stylist, wig designer.
I started doing wigs almost
from the beginning of my career.
This is my 50th year actually.
These are some covers that I'd done
for some beauty magazine.
I used two pounds of hair
to create this style.
I worked for the Kenneth Beauty Salon,
which was at that time, world-renowned,
all the celebrities, all the movie stars,
including people like Jacqueline Onassis
and Marilyn Monroe, were clients there.
I opened my own salon
on the Upper East side.
I was there from 1985 until 2010,
and I moved into the salon
I'm in today at Gloria Wan.
Did you wash this wig?
- [Woman] No, I didn't.
- Okay, let me cut it and then wash it.
So, it takes about five or
six weeks to make a wig.
The job of crocheting the
hair is called ventilating it.
The ventilating needles
come in different sizes,
so if we're doing very
fine work they'll use
a needle that only takes one
or two hairs in each knot.
And if we're using a heavy wig,
we might have a needle
that takes up to 10 hairs in each knot.
Sometimes the more delicate
wigs actually take longer
than the very thick ones.
At one time there was
the synthetic wig boom,
and everybody had a
synthetic wig, and now,
people seem to be much more
interested in the quality,
and they're willing to
spend the money for it.
My custom wigs range
from $38.50 up to $5000.
You know, and I've made wigs for films
that I've had to charge
more than that for,
because I had to do them in a hurry
and pay through the nose to get it done.
My clients are a variety of people.
It's the kind of thing where
you get a lot of satisfaction
when you have clients that
are undergoing medical treatments.
Sometimes, it had actually held them back
from getting their medical treatments
if they told that they
were gonna have hair loss.
And then once they got
the wig and they saw that
they looked as good, or
in many cases even better
than they looked before,
they go into their treatments
with a lot better attitude.
I don't know what sets me apart.
I care about what I do,
and also I know I'm good at it,
and when you're good at
something, you enjoy doing it.